-Our first guest tonight is
an Emmy Award-winning actor,
writer, and co-creator of
the hit series "Ted Lasso."
The season two finale premieres
Friday on Apple TV+.
He'll also be making his return
to "Saturday Night Live,"
this time as host,
with musical guest
Brandi Carlile on October 23rd.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Jason Sudeikis.
How are you, buddy?
-Hi, Seth.
-It's so good to see you.
-Nice to see you, too.
This doesn't -- it feels like...
I can't believe
this is on television.
-Yeah, right?
It seems, like, very shaggy
for a network television show.
-Hey.
-The standards are just dropping
by the day, my friend.
-It's fantastic. It's great.
And then it'll all
come back around.
It's fine.
-Now, I will say one of the nice
things about this year's Emmy,
not just the fact that you guys
won so many deserved awards,
but it did kind of feel
like a party again
after a year where it sort of
had a more maybe funereal vibe.
And you looked like
a million bucks, my friend.
I mean, I was happy
to see you win,
but I was even happier
to see you in this tuxedo.
You got some real good feedback.
-I mean, yeah.
I mean, starting right there
with Kate Winslet.
She walked by me at some point,
and just, like,
rubbed my shoulder.
And I didn't know
if it was 'cause of me
or you know, the couch I was
wearing or what it was.
But whatever worked.
You know, it worked.
-This photo --
this grabs a moment
where a woman is just turning
to go like, "Bugga-wha?!"
[ Laughter ]
-I'll take your word for it.
Yeah, I hadn't seen that photo.
I remember that moment happening
from the first-person
perspective,
but that lets me know
that I was right.
It really did happen.
-We had your wonderful co-star
and fellow writer on the show,
Brett Goldstein here last night.
He was talking about, you know,
it was the first time
he had been at an Emmys.
And how much dread he had
when the music started
and there was an expectation
of dancing.
You were a little bit
more familiar
with what a room like this
would be like.
You're a man who's not
afraid to dance.
But were you aware of how much
you'd be on camera
over the course of the evening?
-Absolutely not.
No, when we got there, like,
our table was
front and center --
or, it was in the round,
but we were right there.
And then my seat was literally
right up in front,
which has never been my move.
I'm much more of a back of the
classroom, you know, whispering,
passing notes, you know,
doing shenanigans.
And to be -- it felt,
yeah, a little bit like
I was, you know, mayor
for a little bit.
Or, you know, like some sort of
where they usually put royalty.
And, so, yeah -- I mean, even
the fact that I had to --
I mean, I joked around.
I was sitting at the table,
and the stage was behind me,
and I was like, "What if I just
sat like this the whole time
and just didn't even
turn around?"
Just ate my little box
of food and...
But, yeah, we had no idea.
I mean, Brett's already reticent
because he's, you know, British
and a writer.
But then to ask him to be at his
first fancy thing like that.
'Cause all the other ones, we've
been doing in this setting.
-Yeah.
-We open up laptops.
And now here we are around
a bunch of fancy folks,
and they want us to dance
right away.
And Rita Wilson set the bar.
You now, and too high,
in my opinion.
-Too high.
It's going to be a very hard bar
for the rest of us to meet, not
just for next year's Emmys,
but I think for all
in the future.
-Yeah, indeed. Yep.
-I want to ask about what must
be very nice for you
is the feedback, not just
from fellow actors,
from fellow comedians, but
so many in the world of sports
are huge fans of "Ted Lasso."
Ted Heads, I believe,
is the terminology.
What are the coaches that you've
been lucky enough to talk to
about your show?
-Well, I mean, early on,
you know, Jim Harbaugh.
He was helpful.
I mean, I actually
reached out to him,
'cause I met him years ago
when he helped us out
on "Detroiters,"
the show that Sam and Tim did
with Joe and Zach,
and we stayed in touch.
And asking him, "Hey, what do
you wear on game days?"
Like, "Do you show up, do you
bring a little duffel bag?"
And he's like, "No, I just show
up in khakis and a sweatshirt."
I was like, "Okay, well, that's
what I'm going to do."
So, you know, I feel like
there's part of him
that feels ownership
over the character.
But heard back from him.
But then some, like, some
really fun ones, you know,
being a basketball fan but
Steve Nash and Steve Kerr.
Steve's son Matthew actually was
one of our writer's assistants
last year.
And this season we name-checked
him in the same episode.
Our little homage to
that father and son duo.
But yeah, we also heard
Juergen Klopp was a big fan.
You know, the Liverpool coach.
-That's a fan.
I mean, the coaches who have
engaged with it are exactly
the coaches you want to have
engaged with it.
-100%.
-And that must be the best.
-Oh, especially when you know,
Steve Nash is a huge fan
of soccer.
Knows the game
really, really well.
He really liked
the commercials too.
So he's been a fan for a spell.
But, like, when you have people
from the soccer/football
community embrace it, you know,
like Thierry Henry --
or, you know, who else?
Oh, I just met Abby Wambach.
Her and her wife Glennon -- or
her girlfriend -- I don't know
their relationship status,
but they were holding hands.
You know, scuttlebutt.
You heard it from me.
[ Laughter ]
I don't care.
I'll put anybody on blast.
Together. Ladies too.
I mean, there you go.
-You're in the public eye.
If people want to hold hands
around you,
that just goes out
to the public.
-[ Laughs ]
That's right.
-You have the eye of the public.
[ Laughter ]
-But the fact that,
like, Abby gave --
Glennon told me that she gave
a standing ovation when we won.
I was like, "That's great."
So that's great when we're even
pulling the wool over
actual footballers' eyes.
-You gave a nice shout-out to
our former boss --
I guess my current boss, who am
I kidding? Lorne Michaels.
You got out. I'm still here.
-Not in two weeks.
He brought me right back in,
the son of gun.
-He did. That's true.
-Oh, boy.
-But have you heard from
Lorne since you -- I mean,
I guess you're talking about
the fact you're going
back to host.
You must have heard from him.
-I saw him after that night.
But, yeah, man, I didn't know.
That was a fun thing.
Bill Lawrence, you know, who
does the show with us was like,
"When you looked over there
and gestured to him,
did you know he wasn't there?"
I go, "No, no.
That was real time."
Like, I brain-farted a few
people that I wanted thank
because I riffed on him
not being there.
I was like, "Well, you know,
we'll make some toilet humor.
Make my folks proud
and move on."
After that he, you know, he gave
some pearls of wisdom
and was just excited about --
We hadn't announced
who the hosts were coming up,
so he was playing it cool there.
-Was one of his pearls of wisdom
don't go to the bathroom when
one of your former castmates
is likely to win an Emmy?
-I mean, yeah, you know,
2021 hindsight we call it now.
-Exactly.
-No, he's always learning.
He's constantly learning.
He's a work in progress.
He'll tell you that
first and foremost.
[ Laughter ]
-That is Lorne.
He's always like,
"I'm not there, Jason."
[ Laughter ]
-"I got so much to learn."
-He always -- Yeah, he goes,
"I don't come into work
because I know who I am.
I come into work
because it's 11:30."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I've seen the trailer.
I'm very excited about this film
that I believe is out on Friday.
"South of Heaven."
-Yeah.
-Very not "Ted Lasso."
It must be fun to sort of do
something noir-ish,
because I feel like I haven't
seen you do that before.
-I know. No, it's not really
a spoiler just 'cause I won't
tell you when I do it
or who I do it towards,
but I shoot a shotgun
in this movie.
-[ Laughs ] Right.
-Yeah. Yeah.
But, no, it's great. Yeah.
It's me and Evangeline Lilly.
A bunch of other folks.
But, yeah, it's like in that
style, like, '70s noir.
You know, when Walter Matthau
would play like a badass
in the movies in the '70s.
I'm looking forward for folks
to see it.
It is very different than
"Ted Lasso."
Even though I have
a Southern accent in it,
but, yeah, there's no soccer
and, you know, not as much
hugging and forgiveness.
-Yeah, less rewarding arcs.
I'm guessing the arcs
are less rewarding.